[Music]
pomona california
a small middle-class town populated by
aspiring artists college students and
car enthusiasts
it's home to lila's restaurant a fine
dining restaurant only eight months old
yet it's days away from closing its
doors hello i'm the owner of a fine
dining restaurant
leela shouldn't be in the downtown
pomona center there's a lot of homeless
people i don't believe that leelas fits
pomona
our restaurant here is crazy i mean
ricky is he's always loud okay all right
let's go you know hey i'm hot
that's what it comes down to like you
walk into a club you know and you just
walk on the dance or just be like
since it's my kitchen my menu you know i
can do that i have a knife brian get
away from me
we clown each other and we have fun
while we're in here what the hell is in
your ear man
like protein can't go maybe i mean this
is the real deal
buzzard like to stand in the kitchen and
eat i like to peck at the food all the
time
you know like one big happy family hey i
need my [ __ ] order now all we do is
read the ticket to put the food out
tabitha man i just have to tell her
chill out no you're right back at her
ass i'm the one having to take this
guy's order and telling him oh we don't
have this and we don't have that don't
blame that [ __ ] on us cause it ain't our
fault ricky i can't stand him you don't
[ __ ] know how to do [ __ ] that's why
this restaurant grunts the problem with
tabitha is how she talks to people
[ __ ] that orders the [ __ ]
man shut up already everybody can hear
ricky and tabitha yelling when they yell
at each other [ __ ] [ __ ] no we all got
[ __ ] now
i think they're overwhelmed in here
it's really embarrassing because your
guests are like
what is going on back there like i just
wanted a salad
like it was slow and then just getting
slower and slower and slower
i'm definitely losing money right now i
took all my retirement money everything
i had saved everything and decided to
open this restaurant i have nothing left
i think we've hit rock bottom i mean
we're like really going down downhill i
just wanted to see if you'd have some
money to lend me for the rent
oh gee
i owe my sister 60 000. how much 3 700.
i owe 64 000 for the line of credit
i'm stressing like how i'm going to pay
my bills and my rent and
what i'm going to do because i don't
want to leave her but i have bills i
have to pay can't sleep at night
only because it's going through my mind
how can i fix it i don't know what to do
[Music]
so downtown pomona uh it's quiet like a
ghost town around here
this is supposed to be fine dining but
it's very very quiet and the place looks
absolutely derelict inside oh my god
i'm excited i want to hear his accent
look at this look at this look at this
look at this later nice to see you nice
to meet you
hi my name's seth and i'm your server
all i know about chef ramsay is he likes
to yell a lot i don't take anybody
yelling at me um nobody and the super
day is what please tomato basil tomato
puzzle profession yes lovely thank you
you're welcome
menu
spelt incorrectly all over the place
are you ready to order what is that
there chivas what is one
c-h-i-v-a-s shivers chives oh chives
kind of spell chive properly
okay try it let's go with
a small bowl of the tomato basil okay
and i'd like to see the naturals we
actually don't have the shrimp nachos
today we have a chicken nacho so no
shrimps today no strips so no shrimp
cocktail either
okay um i like the sign of the salmon uh
we don't have the salmon today we don't
have a summon either yeah no we have
tuna no
i'm not sure okay
okay we don't have anything and it's
really just it's irritating the [ __ ] out
of me because i hate to tell customers
that we don't have anything i'll go for
the
speciality of the house the roasted rack
of lamb the regular
in a chocolate mint sauce please thank
you very much you're very welcome it's
very disappointing when you sit down and
start ordering and then half the food's
not available on the menu
okay this is your order bring it
everything here we don't have he wanted
the shrimp nachos we don't have shrimp
he wanted the shrimp cocktail we don't
have shrimp for us to sit there and have
to tell customers oh we don't have this
and we don't have that it gets
frustrating for me because we should
have everything
[Music]
wow
here you go lovely i'm not nervous at
all what i need to be nervous for
you know he's a man just like i am
interesting
how is everything it tastes like it's
canned
yeah so it says homemade soup on the
menu and it's brought in
can the chef make tomato soup
probably
i thought this was fine darling so did i
so i'll wait for the next course okay
chicken nachos oh that was quick wow
who's that shouting
what what what what what
our executive chef ricky look at them
diamonds on that diamonds on my fish the
diamonds on my fish diamonds on my fish
diamonds on my fish you have an
executive chef in the house yes and he
buys in processed food so what
yes
diamonds
diamond's on my fish we got diamonds on
the fish i'm good at my job i love my
recipe i let my work speak for herself
fine dining nachos something's not quite
right
how is everything uh yeah really weird
are they fresh naturals or are they
brought in uh the chef makes them fresh
in the morning yeah uh i don't think
they were made fresh this morning my
daddy
ricky
when did you make the tortilla chips uh
yesterday i'm about to walk home right
now the nachos like it was the cheapest
thing he's ever seen the [ __ ] can you do
with nachos you know what i mean well
they call them nachos that's why it's an
appetizer you know
oh god
the rack of lamb with the chocolate mint
sauce there's fresh mint
chocolate syrup
[Music]
i like it i got to be really creative
with it
damn that looks good
god i said quick
okay
where's the lamp
no no not that where's the lamp
uh
look
my nice bigger than my lounge
we're going to eat may the lord make us
truly not vomit
it's going to be a long day
could you ask the chef is the lamb
frozen yes
oh the lamb is frozen yes
he's just taking bites and stuff is this
frozen and i'm like
[Music]
yeah
is there any main course that's on the
fine dining menu that's not frozen sad
to say but no
everything is frozen okay um general
i'll skip any further frozen food and
maybe have a nice fresh dessert please
okay i'm hungry i'm starving i'm [ __ ]
eating anything yet
yeah you know you shot everything down
pretty much you know but that's one
person's opinion you know and he's
entitled to it so that's that and what
would you recommend for yourself there
you go for the dessert i would recommend
the brownie a la mode
brownie the brownie alone
and he was like put your hand up and
swear to god that it's a brownie that's
made homemade from here okay all right
let's go with the brownie okay wow what
a shame when you first arrive and you're
excited about coming in to eat somewhere
and then half the menu missing 90 of it
frozen and uh
chocolate mint sauce with bones of lamb
there was a big ass pan in here full of
[ __ ] brownies i go in there and
there's no more homemade brownies
i don't know what happened to the
brownies i didn't do it don't actually
buzz it i don't know does anybody know
what happened to that big thing of
brownies that were in there
when
a couple days ago why
they were just in there like three days
ago it irritates the living daylights
out of me
we should have everything that is on our
menu at all times and we don't i'm just
i'm gonna quit
[ __ ] dad don't even talk like that man
you let one [ __ ] just piss you
off like that no you piss me off because
you don't [ __ ] run this [ __ ] man we
should have all this [ __ ]
you know it's on the [ __ ] are you
talking about you coming back here
asking me what's in this what's in that
you should know that [ __ ] already
[ __ ] all right then no [ __ ]
ass me [ __ ]
no we don't got [ __ ] now
[ __ ] all right
you shut the [ __ ] up
what's going on
you coming back here asking me what's in
this what's in that you should know that
[ __ ] already [ __ ] all right
there's no [ __ ]
[ __ ]
no we don't got [ __ ] now you shut the
[ __ ] up
what's going on
she always want to blame people for
other [ __ ] she should know the menu
don't come back there asking me you know
what's in the [ __ ] kitchen you know
what's frozen what's not what the [ __ ]
you gotta ask me for right
um what was fine dining about my lunch
there what do you mean okay let's put it
this way then
i thought it was a pile of [ __ ]
i was embarrassed for you
okay
you can't serve [ __ ] lamb with
chocolate sauce i mean are you mad
there's no meat on the lamb you don't
blame me for no meat on a lamb that's
just what we buy here that's what we
serve ricky it's on the menu at 27
nobody else complaining about it there's
nobody else in the restaurant
i was bitching about the chocolate mint
sauce on the lamb people like that
believe it or not they come in here and
order it all the time so i'm not gonna
pull it from my menu just because you
don't like it what was fresh on the menu
as far as not being frozen as far as not
being frozen not being brought in
everything has to be frozen we just
can't let stuff go bad you know
have you got any bulls got big nuts just
cause you come in here and criticize my
place you think i'm gonna give up
nah whose balls i think are bigger his
or mine put it like this we're gonna
bump heads i'm standing in front of a
man that i feel that's got his name on
his jacket all the big showbiz
embroidery and yet we're serving frozen
vegetables as a chef don't you feel
embarrassed about what you're serving no
i don't otherwise i wouldn't serve it
are you lazy
[Music]
after yesterday's fiasco at lunch day
two begins with gordon inspecting
executive chef ricky's kitchen
[Music]
god a fridge that's not even cold this
is not a refrigeration unit this is
almost like an oven all this meat is
there's virtually rotting dried
warm congealed blood at the bottom there
the smell is just vile what is that
god what the smell
jesus
it's christ
i'm slowly but surely discovering my
lunch the bought in tomato and basil
soup that's finished with chili flakes
there's nothing freshly made in this
fridge
[ __ ] here now
it [ __ ] stinks
the lack of cleanliness represents a
lack of discipline and gordon knows he
needs to send a strong message to the
staff we've got to clean
ricky i want the fridge walls scrubbed
the floor done yeah bucket's behind you
yeah tabitha take care of the dying room
gordon had us clean the dining room
freaking sweep like three times mop do
all the windows everything with a
concern that fine dining might not be
right for this part of pomona while the
staff cleans gordon hits the streets to
check out the neighborhood
how are you i'm real good good you're
good what's the vibe like here holmen
it's young vibrant diverse what about
leela's the restaurant leela's have you
been there i have not been there
what kind of food you eat uh the pizza
giant right here what about fine dining
usually not too fancy
kind of on a budget no you keep the
fancy stuff for your arms right yeah huh
and where would you go to eat there's
like some pretty good mexican
restaurants but like besides that there
isn't really anywhere that's like in our
price range
with a better sense of what will work in
this community gordon heads back to
lila's to check on the staff's
assignment
nice nice nice nice looks fantastic
yes clean
while gordon is now happy with the
cleanliness of the restaurant he is
still not comfortable with the relaxed
atmosphere that's not what your sister
told me last night
this is kind of like home you know just
kind of hang out talk to everybody
on the phone
i just lounge
[Music]
we have fun while we're in here i mean
what's the use of having a job that
you're not happy with we haven't met you
have we uh no i'm not awesome boys
that's right you like to stand in the
kitchen and eat you know you always
catch him with something in his hand i
think he got a tape on him
the evening started out slowly but a
local theater has let out and a wave of
customers has now arrived at the
restaurant follow me and i'll go ahead
and seat you
[Music]
all right ricky where's my salmon that's
supposed to be split don't be in such a
[ __ ] hurry to do [ __ ]
holy smoke it quickly becomes obvious to
gordon that this restaurant does not
have a leader just two major opponents
ricky in the kitchen and tabitha in the
front of the house
salmon in a sea bass split
huh no sea bass [ __ ] man how come you
didn't tell me that when you seen the
ticket without your seated ticket
i'm like really frustrated with ricky um
us not having everything they would sit
in there for 15 20 minutes when their
food should be coming out any minute
i just found out that we have no sea
bass
is that what we both ordered yeah
ricky doesn't have many of the food
items that are on the menu and what they
do have is pre-packaged and overpriced
for the town of pomona i just tasted
this it tastes like powdered mashed
potato they are
they taste alright you put a little
butter in them whatever put the sauce
over and they taste okay nobody's ever
complained about them
i didn't even know that he was using
instant potatoes i think ricky's a
little lazy
holy mackerel it's out of date yeah yeah
look at the day february 16th what's the
date today do not serve that [ __ ]
cake
end the [ __ ] story yes
then in a dinner service that's not
exactly smooth sailing some of the staff
start abandoning ship caroline i'm going
home we're still busy here
the brush is over when
are we finished or no i'm just taking a
break
he's walking down alley right now with
his bag of goodies
that's the buzzer though you know so
he's always waiting to grab something
with his damn claws
[Music]
buzzard and one of the cooks have walked
off but they are not empty-handed
[Music]
more of you go in there got a sandwich
from earlier um some pasta that somebody
ordered and they didn't want jesus lemon
there as well yeah okay
did you ask anyone for it
no
you need to go talk to her and let her
know i have no problem with it okay
we'll go together
we wonder why there's things missing
after he's gone
this is buzzard's little little picnic
nice little sandwich there ham cheese
mustard oh nice pink salad and main
course we're going to tackle some new
zealand lamb no you know where that came
from stop laughing here we are with the
restaurant there's financially [ __ ]
screwed and you're just helping yourself
to wine and a full course dinner he
takes little things every now and then
but i haven't seen him do something like
that in a while
you're talking about aren't you working
this lady
[Music]
gordon caught buzzard taking food and
wine from the restaurant and gordon is
not happy
this lady owns it
unbelievable we were thinking that he
was doing that but i hadn't caught him
in the act and today well
there it is
christ almighty guys
what are we doing here
just our basics isn't even together as a
team i can't take responsibility for for
the whole restaurant failing it's you
know this is the team effort here why
did you become a chef because i have a
passion for food that's why
a passion for what
food
you're making powdered mashed potato
you talk about the mashed potatoes i
didn't hear not one person complaining
about him tonight did you
what
did you when ricky and gordon were going
at it i really wanted to just like tell
ricky to shut up where's your respect
what do you mean where's my respect for
your professionalism
you are not an executive chef let's get
that right
don't look at me like that you back a
dog into a corner eventually you know
what i'm saying he's going to bite you
know
i'd rather change my career and make it
out of powdered mash
anything you'd like to say before we go
home
i just hope everybody's attitude changes
tomorrow so we can turn this restaurant
around if you still have attitudes
then um there's gonna have to be some
changes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's day three and gordon is about to
put his plan into action but one of last
night's problems has returned
[Music]
buzzer's here
where is he
in the back
i hate to have to fire anybody but then
you get to the point where you know if i
can't get them to change what they're
doing or whatever then i have to get rid
of them
can i see your eyes can you take glasses
off
um
anything that's inside this restaurant
belongs to leela yeah right yeah end of
story nothing gets taken off those
premises
if it was up to me i'd fire buzzard's
ass i get lots of people stealing from
me and i just have one discipline anyone
steals from me is out end the story
because the message you send they will
see you doing it they all do it anyway
lena you're the one's gonna make the
decision it's your question yeah
so you know i'm sorry but this is gonna
be it
all right
this is it
buzzard ain't gonna be back here he
ain't gonna be buzzing around here and
he's truly a buzzard let me get my bag
and my bunny okay
now that buzzard has been let go gordon
turns his attention back to the chefs
okay ricky let's go
oh boy
[Music]
okay little taste test yeah
last night for me there wasn't enough
tasting going on there wasn't enough
identification so i'm gonna pass you a
little bit of food and i want you to
taste it okay and then i'm gonna ask you
what it is okay are you ready
yeah yeah good i didn't know what to
expect when he blindfolded us for the
most part i do taste my food okay good
so
one of my favorite meats
ricky what was that it was beef
legs tastes like chicken
you're right ricky
you're wrong
that was chicken
what
are you gonna mistake chicken for beef
that just blew me out of the water
[Music]
ricky
what was that
i said it was pork
pork
legs what was that tastes like new york
beef
yep lex
is new york strip
jesus we already knew that lex was gonna
get more because ricky doesn't taste his
food did you brush your teeth this
morning
holy mackerel
right blindfolds off
i
expected you to get all of these right
and you didn't
out of both of you who is the better
cook i'm the better cook
you're looking at him well he certainly
proves it on the taste test thank you
i am the better chef
definitely you know without having to
think about it ricky happy with that
no not necessarily lex sandy's a better
chef than me i know where my skills are
i know what i can do i know what i do in
here on a daily basis you know otherwise
you have a switch round yes
leena i just found your new head chef
don't expect you to just bark at me and
not expect me to say nothing back cause
that that [ __ ] ain't gonna happen i
don't wanna hear [ __ ] from you
day four and to get ready for tonight's
relaunch gordon moves to the next phase
of his plan but first a surprise for the
owner
you my dear yeah for the last eight
months okay have been taking care of
everybody yes yeah you're not doing that
any longer i've arranged for you to go
off somewhere really luxurious and to be
taken care of oh you're going off this
afternoon
for a bit of a makeover pampering i'm
looking forward to the uh day off and
not having to worry about this place and
kind of relax a little bit
hi welcome to i'm sheri i'm leela i hear
you're in need of a pampering commander
while leela gets her makeover gordon
begins to change the menu from fine
dining to contemporary casual starting
with a signature salad i want you to
think both of you yeah of a pomona salad
pomona yeah it's got a nice ring to it
just over the next hour
put together
a pomona salad i want you to think of
something exciting and i'm telling you
this is how caesar salad started if
bloody caesar can do it pomona can do it
use your imagination go through the
fridge look at the peppers whether you
grill them soda them or sweets out
barbecue them i don't care give it some
attitude well the pomona salad he
basically said you know try to get the
feel of pomona here a little salt in
there get away absolute tip top get the
black beans onto there and the chicken
onto there this guy just opened up a
three million dollar restaurant of
course i'm gonna try and get all the
pointers i can from here like i'm back
in school you know i felt like i was
right back in the classroom you know
scurrying around into walking looking
for this looking in the reaching oh what
can i put in this you know what i mean
right wash your hands uh clear the bench
off legs please i want to see what
you've done both of you yeah
we have a new
pomona salad
a salad that is in keeping with the area
it's fresh it's new it's vibrant
the pomona salad is wonderful
i don't know how to describe the taste
to it but it just it tastes really
really good
i walked them down the streets saw
chinese food mexican food a pizza era
and what no one has out there is a
bloody good burger
and i'm gonna show you how to make a
stunning delicious burger you know i
could have made a burger but a burger to
me is basic chopped beef salt pepper
dijon mustard worcester sauce ketchup
finely chopped onions three egg yolks to
bind it together really important to mix
all that through yeah yes really
important tonight we're gonna do a
special leela's famous burger yes will
be the best burger in pomona i
definitely feel like our leela's famous
burger is really gonna help us attract
more people grill it nicely this is
perfect this grill
have a little taste
season wise that's fine let's put the
burger on as a special tonight chef
gordon he was right when he said that we
needed a burger you can't get a burger
around here nowhere pomona needs a great
burger and tonight he's gonna get one
the recipe to the lita's burger is top
secret i can tell you but then i have to
kill you
armed with lila's new hamburgers a
catering truck and enthusiasm gordon and
the staff hit the streets to promote the
restaurant
can i interest you in a free burger sure
sure i love free burgers what about you
i think that the word will get out on
the street that we have a really juicy
burger you're welcome thank you free
burger free burger all right so how was
it
nice we like another one i'm gonna get
another one it's also gonna get on the
street that chef gordon made it
surprising how happy everybody is on the
back of a really good delicious simple
burger the garbage is
excellent
while the staff promotes the new burgers
gordon's design team makes over the
restaurant in anticipation of tonight's
relaunch we've got a new plan a new menu
and a new interior leela's because we're
giving a new look yeah a new
unintimidating yeah warm place yes yes
speaking of new looks leela
where are you my darling here we are
look at you
look at you hello good morning
[Music]
when i seen leila come around the corner
and made me cry because she looks so
much happier uh how'd you feel my daddy
good yeah let me say you look great
thank you yes you don't look like a lady
who's carrying the world on our
shoulders anymore when they saw me they
said
oh my god you look so different i said
yes you have a new boss are you ready to
see the new
hot spot in downtown pomona yes
okay are you ready on the count of three
three
[Applause]
guys come here come here come here come
here
come here come in when they opened up
the doors i was really shocked and
surprised it looks so much nicer you
know it's warm yes it's inviting
it's no longer stark and cold
you've got the reception here you've got
chairs sit down
what first caught my eye was the the red
couch the candles like why didn't we
think of that you know it's in keeping
with downtown pomona oh my god look at
our station
i think that gordon did the right thing
for our restaurant just more positive
energy from all of us it's one hour
before the opening and gordon has
mainstreamed the menu gone are the fine
dining efforts like chocolate lamb chops
and soggy chicken nachos and in their
place are popular fair like leela's
famous burgers and the new pomona salad
[Music]
all that's left to do is get the
personnel in order we need a leader we
need a manager and we need to install
some form of discipline
[Music]
tabitha manage the place yeah
it means a lot to me that gordon went
with the whole idea of me becoming
manager that just shows me that she
knows that i can do it lex can i have
you running the kitchen tonight
it's like it's the biggest compliment
i've had all my life so far ricky
support it properly yes i think it's
fair i've been here since day one busted
my butt you know what i mean let's get
some identity and work together as a
team i'd rather have somebody like lex
who's passionate about what he does i
really don't think that ricky's attitude
will change this restaurant needs to
turn tables tonight to stay open
tomorrow
[Music]
it's relaunch night and gordon has
invited local artists students and car
clubs to experience the new leelas and
now regardless of the rain the
restaurant is packed open the new leelas
let's go all right
good luck guys yes yeah you're gonna
need it let's go
good evening how are you
let's open the doors right now man we
got a house full of people man
when i looked outside and i saw this
long line i said oh my god are they
gonna be able to handle it it's awesome
this is our new and improved menu i'm
pretty nervous about tonight because i
know that it's going to be brand new
leela's this is our new menu the
restaurant's menu has been totally
revamped by gordon to better suit the
casual neighborhood and tonight for the
first time the man in charge of the
kitchen is sous chef lex
lex is the chef tonight you got it yes
it hurts i don't [ __ ] care
you know i'm not gonna i'm not gonna cry
about it i take responsibility take it
like a man pretty much uh lex yes i want
you calling out the orders tonight yes
yeah don't forget got it i'm feeling
really anxious a little nervous because
i know it's a big night for us true
specials bacon and cheese comes with
bacon monterey jack and swiss cheese
there you go that sounds fantastic
yeah they're not hanging around they're
just coming straight in there yes here
comes the beer and to further endear
this restaurant to the community gordon
has arranged for the mayor of pomona to
be here tonight i want you to come in
and sit down we have a special table for
you thank you all right what table is in
there sat on 55. see where that lady is
with the red okay yes okay ryan
are we ready to order
ricky don't [ __ ] off outside on the
phone keep it going yes me legs ricky we
you know we
we don't want to mess up what are you
eating now every time i look at you
you're always eating this is work now
yeah so when you want to get in work
mode yes
yeah and for yourself i'm going to try
the pot roast i'm gonna have the
burger the evening has started off well
with customers responding favorably to
the new casual menu
listen lex first table absolutely
critical but the real hard work is about
to hit the staff and a little stage
fright has set in
where's the tickets for these chefs
lex where's the ticket going for the
tomorrow it's already been taken [ __ ]
you now
closer to 30. 30 minutes into service
and leelis is off to a rocky start
where's the first ticket alex no food
has left the kitchen and this grand
reopening is off course hey guys we're
falling behind we've got to wrap up a
little bit yeah yeah what's going next
is that the pomona salad there needs
chicken
where's the chicken
oh come on guys
listen relax yes work together and send
one table at a time okay there's a lot
of pressure
working in the kitchen so i thought
we're gonna go screw it all up if this
doesn't work i don't know what's gonna
work to be honest the worst thing that
could happen probably let's run in the
kitchen tonight they started to become
clear now i don't think any of them are
used to being busy so that's why they're
so far in this [ __ ] and the tuna
sandwich and when food finally does come
out of the kitchen not everyone at the
table is getting their food at the same
time
so i'll just eat this
and
[Music]
don't panic i'm just trying to send it
at the same [ __ ] time that's all yeah
making it into your personal right yeah
the baker's not even [ __ ] cut you
know it's stone cold it's not even
crispy we've got it we've got at least
put it back on the grill for 30 seconds
come on guys
[ __ ] meltdown
we haven't had any food yet you had any
food whatsoever i ordered four times
already
it seems to be taking a little too long
to get our salad i'm irritated i'm very
very irritated tonight everything is not
going the way that it was supposed to go
for a chicken sandwich oh my god oh my
god
chicken sandwich is going with the uh
they just took they just took the salad
they just took the salad what's going on
well the greeting likes it's not paying
attention to their tickets right here
the wait staff begins to panic get on
the computer fix all that [ __ ] so we
don't need the [ __ ] key anymore how
about that
grabbing whatever food is up on the
counter regardless of which table it
belongs to
i don't know what was going on in the
kitchen i don't even know where my order
is like i'm i don't care famous burger
table eleven
black and family what did you order
oh man they put the wrong order in it's
supposed to go out with table ten
caroline you put in table 11 for this
and they're they're saying it's not
theirs
it's a salmon and a bake in a
cheeseburger it's like like a train ring
did you have the chicken soup no okay
tonight was
overwhelming
sorry
no he doesn't if i said his coming he's
coming i need a capillary shrimp i i
just told you i just told you it's
coming right now don't ask him cause he
don't know
one hour into dinner service and lex's
inexperience begins to show they're
taking different food from different
orders and that's not helping us at all
you stand there say nothing i've been
telling them who have you told me i
called ricky already and we were trying
to talk to them
as the police yes right there okay likes
was trying to say that the whole
confusion was um because of the front of
the house
freaky want to try to blame that
everything's messed up right now because
of the front of the house [ __ ]
don't blame that [ __ ] on us cause it
ain't our fault all we do is read the
ticket to put the food out trying to
stay on track with the orders and they
just keep yelling out they need table 55
they need this table they need that
table you know people were trying to ask
me 50 million things at one time so it's
it's a lot of chaos it's it's a lot of
pressure
you need it she needs it where's my
famous pig
what the [ __ ] hurry up hurry up come on
you got to be fast buddy he freezes he
doesn't know what to do i i have to go
back there and actually help tell him
okay look at this is what we need to do
can somebody please answer me
all right
lex
what's going on
frustrated and completely overwhelmed
what the hell am i doing here lex leaves
the kitchen to go cool off outside
legs come back here
lex is panicking on us meanwhile leela
is in the middle of the dining room
fielding complaints
you're waiting for grilled salmon yeah
okay let me go see what happened there
where's black they're waiting out there
for two salads everybody else got their
food i guess there was two up here that
he put up here i don't know what
happened to him the point is they're not
there all right and i need the two
salmon where's black knowing how
critical tonight's dinner service is
leela finally becomes a boss get in
there there's two salmons people waiting
for the salmons why are you here don't
talk to me like that don't be out of
here all right there was something
going on with lex and um the boss leela
some words were exchanged because he
wanted a break and she yelled at him i
don't appreciate that kind of talk i
don't appreciate it
well i don't know if you answered me
that way okay i asked you there's two
what do you want there's people out
there you guys are all here i can't get
it right for five minutes i've been
working for the past four hours straight
everybody has you're not the only one
yeah but you haven't been cooking that's
the same thing you're not any harder
than ours you're not working in the heat
like i am well if you can't handle it
then leave
she totally snapped and i
i thought she was kidding no she was she
was serious you know i'm tired of these
people not doing what they're supposed
to do they just get up and walk out
whenever they feel like it and i'm not
gonna deal with that anymore lex
what's going on
she's just really getting on my nerves
like i'm trying to take a five minute
break at least you know that's when i
got upset like what the hell i've been
working all night we're not quitting are
you what the hell am i doing here no
okay i can understand i can feel the
frustration yeah tonight was a tough
night hey
lex
get your ass back here yes
he's really upset right now okay cool
him down yeah i'm trying i'm trying to
i'm trying to go
[Music]
damn
[Music]
[Applause]
damn
with lex out of the kitchen all the
pressure is on ricky to get leela's back
under control where's my cream at
where's my cream where's my cream ricky
yes keep it going yes yes sure if this
slows down now we're all screwed yes yes
gotcha i can still do it when it's time
you know it's crunch time you know just
kick it out table 55 is for the mayor
how long for that table vvip 35 minutes
five minutes please oh hell what is all
this [ __ ] can i get the ticket when you
drop my order please you sure can many
people are still waiting for food
including the mayor of pomona and the
pressure in the kitchen is at its peak
burger where's it at is that for table
one is that the ticket for table one
it's [ __ ] busy right now
so we're just you know pretty much all
gonna have to step our game up you got
veggie in the pot right there give me
the pot roast let's move it let's move
let's move it thank you yeah give me two
chicken soups and get this ticket up out
of here bam with ricky back in control
food is flying out of the kitchen
how'd you like your pot roast but it was
worth the wait okay thank you some
people won't complain they're like when
are we gonna get our food and when they
got their food we're like oh we don't
mind the weight you know what if i would
embarrass myself i'd lick that plate
right that's the mayor's table finished
yes hallelujah
and the mayor is proud to have this
restaurant in pomona pomona salad i
think we will declare that officially
the meal for any pomona day seven
hundred dollars you have to pay the
[ __ ] electricity bill and a thousand
dollars to [ __ ] break even you gotta
go yeah keep going gotta go gotta go
gotta go
how's everything perfect great the menu
is great i mean people they really like
the food
after taking a little time to cool off
lex returns to leela's not as head chef
but as ricky's number two liters burger
right here
hey dude sam come on rick we can do this
rick here me and you rick lex took off
and then he came back just cover your
ass ah you know it and we did make a
great turnaround i got chicken ready all
right cool i already got these two right
here okay toad give me a pomona salad
and give me a pop rope i was proud to
see frankie really stepping foot in
taking care of you know situation he
definitely acted as the head chef thank
you very much let's see nice to see it
looks like it's a whole new beginning
really for the restaurant
ricky two seconds
after a dramatic comeback gordon was
truly impressed with ricky we got off to
a rocky start yeah yeah and within 24
hours of being in this restaurant i
thought you were gonna [ __ ] bowl
seriously i thought you're gonna throw
in the towel i just wanted to say
you did well tonight huh thank you sir
we butter heads at first you know but
that was just you know
ego pride pretty much you know what i'm
saying arrogance on my part i just want
to say tonight you proved me wrong and i
thought you did a [ __ ] good job
and in amongst all the commotion the
dying room you really held it together
you were solid you were straight and you
didn't blow it and i just wanted to say
[ __ ] well done because it means a lot
so seriously back though feels good to
be back it does for him to pull me aside
look at me man the man and say you know
you did a great job you know that made
me feel really good but now that you've
opened the door don't [ __ ] close it
keep it cool you know what the score is
now
yeah right don't stop
yeah yes
during the rest of gordon's stay ricky
continues to improve
all right okay cool
tabitha settled into her new role as
manager you feel yourself losing your
mind take a deep breath and breathe
leela continues to be more of a boss and
more assertive with her staff i want
that calamari now
customers raved about the food
and leela's finally for the first time
in eight months made some money never
seen that before
but i'm excited i'm excited come back
again oh yes we will okay all right have
a good night thank you
[Music]
all right let's confirm one thing shall
we you won your first battle
[Music]
chef gordon is amazing dude you fought
to keep your jobs
it proved a point thank god he came and
he helped us you know he turned it
around and you look of the restaurant
the new menu everything's like way
better it was a buzz
a nice loud buzz
the changes that he made here they're
great okay
good night
i'm glad that he was here he had a hand
you know and helping change the
restaurant around you know i thank him
for that
from this day forward i'm gonna remember
everything he said
in spite of business picking up at the
restaurant leela's debts were too large
to overcome and she was forced to close
her doors